and so while we are kind of on the topic
of snitches I do kind of want to go and
just Wow before we wrap up the show talk
about the gun provisions that were in
this law because those were a big deal
obviously we've had a lot of shootings
lately and there's been a lot of people
demanding that Congress do something and
in this bill they did something but
there are some things in here that well
let's just get into it so one of the
things that made it into law attach the
Omnibus is the stopped school Violence
Act which is named great but this is
where the snitches come in what it
actually does is it gives money to
states to create systems for anonymous
reporting of threats which I kind of
have 1984 on the brain I read that book
I love that book it just kind of reminds
me of how that that idea of us telling
on each other that's what we're gonna do
in schools to stop school violence so is
the idea that if someone's not mentally
stable and you have a classmate who
you're concerned about you can contact
someone within the school and the
administration will sort of handle it is
that the idea I think that's the idea
but isn't that exactly what happened in
parkland I mean how many times does that
can have to be reported you're right
yeah and I don't even know why you would
need funding for such a thing I mean it
seems like maybe some like public
service announcement the students should
know that there are resources when they
can go to in case they are concerned
about a fellow student but it doesn't
seem like it would cost that much money
well what they're using the money for is
that they're going to allow these
schools to create apps so it's okay that
type of thing it's the development of
the system kind of like like I live in
California we have a system that's
called Bart is our it's basically our t
our public transportation system and
there's an app where if there's
something going on in my train I can
just kind of tell Bart that it's going
on that's how I'm kind of picturing what
they're trying to do here with these
grants I think that makes sense because
people are so used to just using an app
on their smartphone not as many people
these days are willing to make that
phone call
even if it is for circumstances as dire
as this is it's true
I guess I'm just uncomfortable with the
idea of setting up a
for students to tattle on other students
for things especially where it's already
been proven to be ineffective yeah it
does seem like one of these right-wing
policies that are intended to solve gun
violence without actually getting to the
root of the problem which is guns and I
think there are some things I could get
behind when it comes to like Republican
supportive provisions like for example
even having metal detectors at the
entrances to these schools I think that
could work even having some armed
security guards there may be some
concessions I would make with the right
winger but that would have to come with
like concessions of their own yeah it's
funny that you say that because that's
actually part of these grants to your
these schools are gonna be able to
install metal detectors and other tech
in the schools but isn't that kind of
gun control though if you're saying
we're gonna install metal detectors to
prevent the guns even getting in the
door isn't that almost an admonition
that having the guns in there makes
everything more dangerous I think it
certainly does defeat their argument
than having more guns and more places is
going to be safer for all of us that's
for sure
I don't think they would look at it as a
constitutional violation especially
because you know this is a place
intended for the most vulnerable all of
us like our kids are supposed to be
going into here and certainly when it
comes the students like they have no
right to bear arms if they're under the
age of 18 so I don't know if they would
see it as any legal problem per se yeah
and I actually have no problem with the
metal detector thing I just find it kind
of fascinating that that did make it
into the law that we're gonna give money
for metal detectors where the idea
behind metal detectors and me like we're
gonna have a safe space without guns in
it and it's safe because there are no
guns but yeah so that's one of the
things that they put in the law it's
just these grants to the states
it doesn't really limit anything another
law that made it into law as part of the
omnibus is the fixed NICs act is what
they call it and this uses money to
encourage the federal agencies to add
people who shouldn't be sold guns to the
background check system and I think this
comes from was it Sutherland Springs was
the ex-military guy in Texas right yeah
I think it was him where he was supposed
to be
the background check system because he
had been either prosecuted or something
for domestic violence but he was
supposed to be on the list and the
military never put him on the list and
so I think this is a solution to that I
guess I mean it's good and all but I
think it's similar half thing happened
in Charleston South Carolina Dylan roof
the background process was just a little
bit longer if it take if it took like a
few more days potentially that shooting
wouldn't have happened because he
wouldn't have been able to get access to
a gun and so those nine people in
Charleston at that church wouldn't have
died so maybe this will do some good I
mean it is something it's not nothing
which is nice and then the other thing
it does this was a this has been a
long-term complaint that people have had
that there was a provision put in laws
years ago I don't even know when but the
CDC wasn't allowed to conduct research
on the causes of gun violence and so
this doesn't technically change the law
but the explanatory statement which it's
kind of like an authorization that goes
along with this funding bill that said
that the CDC is allowed to do this
research however even though it was
attached to a government funding log
there was no additional money given to
the CDC to do any extra studies and so
who knows if these studies are actually
going to happen especially well the
Trump administration is in charge so
technically they're allowed to but
there's nothing here indicating that
it's going to happen in real life right
I think it's just Republicans trying to
get away with what little gun control
they can and kind of offer that to
liberals as a win for them it's just
like the idea of banning bumps talks
yeah I think it's a way to kind of calm
down the roar and be like see we did
something you know but this bill also
did something else and this is not a new
provision but it's also one that we
never talked about so I wanted to
highlight it this is in the Department
of Defense division and what it does is
it prohibits the Department of Defense
from disposing of and I have a graphic
here showing these it prohibits the
Department of Defense from disposing of
m1 carbine rifles and one garland rifles
I don't know if I'm saying that
correctly but m14 rifle rifles 22
caliber rifles 30 caliber rifles
or m1911 pistols or to destroy
ammunition that is allowed to be
commercially sold so these weapons here
are military weapons these are weapons
of war and the military because we know
I mean I mean at least I know I read
these things but every year we're buying
more and more guns more and more rifles
through the military and so what we're
doing with the old ones is we're making
sure that the military gets them into
civilian hands we're making sure that
the military is giving them to these
businesses that can then go ahead and
sell them to us for what purposes we're
killing in the United States whether
it's killing a rabbit or a person the
result is just the same these guns are
going from the military to us and this
provision is making sure of it
so why are we focusing on these three
provisions that do almost nothing while
allowing this to stay in the bill and I
get I get the collector aspect of this I
think that's where this is coming from
because there are people that simply
love guns I've heard people actually use
the phrase the beautiful gun but I know
that that's a thing it might not be my
thing but it's still a weapon of war
there are people who worship with their
guns in church I would never do that
it's it's bizarre to me and I guess
that's one of the reasons why I have a
tough time with this topic but it's one
thing to take an old weapon that is at
least disabled you know if you if you
want to appreciate the weapon itself put
it up on your wall like that makes sense
to me but taking these rifles which are
able to be jerry-rigged
into automatic weapons because some of
them were automatic weapons from what I
understand these are weapons of war they
don't belong in our civilization and
it's one thing to it's one thing to let
the military decide what to do with them
it's another to say hey military even if
you want to trash these and keep them
out of civilian hands you can't and that
was in this law too and I don't know why
there's no focus on this probably cuz no
one reads these bills that no one knows
that it's in there but anyway I want to
think I want to thank you pat because
you really walked me through this so
thank you I want to thank David Pakman
for letting me steal his audience for
the day and if you guys are interested
in more Congress
you can find me on the Congressional
dish pad cast which is available
anywhere podcasts are found iTunes
Spotify I Heart Radio and then I also
provide all of my sources of this
information on congressional disco but
thanks for having me this was really fun
the video you just watched was made
possible by support from you please go
to patreon.com slash david pakman show
you can make a pledge of as little as
one dollar per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad